the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
so when we talked about learning we said
that you know everything we know comes
from learning except that which is given
to us by our genes our knowledge of how
to walk around in the world to read to
think to talk to feel the values we have
the hopes we have the fears we have
they're all learned through experience
and then we talk about another approach
to thinking about how we learn things
through memory and today I'm going to
talk about what we understand to be the
brain organization of human memory and
Oliver Sacks
in the chapter and the lost Mariner
chapter 2 talks about one of the two
major kinds of amnesia the loss of
memory due to a brain disorder of brain
injury but he has a very nice language
from Liesman yell talking about memory
you have begun to lose your memory if
only in bits and pieces to realize that
memory is what makes our life life
without memories no life at all our
memories our coherence our reason our
feeling even our action without it we
are nothing I can only wait for the
final amnesia the one that erases an
entire life as I did my mother's right
so our memories of our lives what we've
done you know where we've been what
mattered to us that's a huge piece of
who we are and he runs into a patient
who has who came into the hospital early
1975 with a note saying helpless
demented confused and disoriented he had
a perty had what we call clinically
korsakoff's syndrome see these are
individuals who have a severe alcoholism
for many years and a subset of those
people develop a severe memory disorder
like this man he's 49 years old he tells
sachs about his life details of his life
going into World War two that he worked
on a submarine and so on and it says
Sachs has a full an interesting life
remember visually in detail but for some
reason his memory stopped around World
War two then he asked him what year is
it remember the years 1975 and he says
it's 1945 what do you mean we've won the
war FDR Franklin Delano Roosevelt is
dead Truman's at the helm these are
great times ahead and Jimmy how old
would you be he stopped he said well I
guess I'm 19 that would
have been his age you know 20 years ago
right 30 years ago so you know he's
stuck in time he thinks it's
historically a while ago he has two
completely wrong age and sex takes out a
mirror and throws the denim and says
what do you you know what happened and
he gets he says Jesus Christ what's
going on what happened is this a
nightmare my craziest as a joke such as
if he's lost the last 30 years of his
life and he's living as if it were 30
years ago and then when he walks back in
he's hardly recognized Sachs is hardly
recognized by the person on intelligence
he shows excellent ability but his
memory is very quickly he forgets things
what is this I asked him rubbing a photo
in the magazine I was holding it's the
moon no it's not if it's a picture of
the Earth taken from the moon I mean
don't forget 1945 nobody imagined that
we would be sending up people to the
moon right and taking pictures from the
moon of the earth you're used to it is
nothing to you no it's not it's a
picture taken for the moon doc you're
kidding somebody would have to get a
camera up there naturally hell you're
joking how would you know that so he has
um you know he's has lost the last 30
years of his life for all practical
purposes despite normal intelligence and
normal thought so we're going to talk
more about how this occurs in patients
and other patients and and more
generally how the brain supports you
ability to learn things so here's this
remarkable brain right and in one sense
you could say it's almost all there to
absorb things in life right yeah you
know you have very small insects that
can do a lot with the genes are given we
have big brains to sort of learn the
life we lead and I'm going to come back
at the end to this metaphor with the
idea that in many ways your brain as you
sit there right now or any healthy brain
is kind of like a symphony orchestra
that has many specialized instruments
for learning different kinds of things
and you feel like a unified whole and
you are and these instruments interact
with each other but just like a symphony
orchestra you know together they make a
sound so imagine you're a Martian who
lands outside of Symphony Hall and you
hear a symphony playing is something
beautiful
well that sounds really interesting if
you're a Martian on the outside of the
Symphony Hall how many instruments are
you guessing how many things you might
you guess they are making that sound
would you have any idea one big one two
big ones fifty you would be very hard to
guess and it's only been in the last 20
years or so that we had some real
clarification on the instruments of
learning in our brains so I'm going to
talk about three things today and Tara
great amnesia the loss of the ability to
form new memories retrograde amnesia the
loss of memories you already had an idea
of memory systems this idea that each of
us is has a symphony of learning
instruments in our brain that empowers
us to learn different kinds of things so
integrity shows again the inability to
remember new information and people
mostly talk about two kinds but as you
see there most of life okay not all of
it we'll talk about that but a lot of it
such as events you experience or facts
you encounter so think about this all
the events you've remembered from your
entire life all the facts you've ever
learned in school at home on the
computer that's a huge amount of what
you know and a patient like we just
described with patients I'll describe in
a moment lose the ability to remember
any event from the day they become a
music or remember much in the way of new
information of any kind in terms of
facts of the world so in what sense is
memory in the brain distributer
localized in what sense is in one place
or many places and this has been a sort
of a central debate as in all of
neuroscience but in memory too and Karl
Lashley a sort of giant of neuroscience
or just to t-stops away at Harvard so
this it's not possible to demonstrate
the isolated localization of a memory
trace anywhere in the nervous system the
Engram is represented throughout the
brain the engrams kind of a magic word
in memory in the brain the Engram is the
thing in you that changes in your brain
that is the stuff of a memory if you
learn today that there's you know more
terrible news in Japan with the nuclear
reactors and you remember that because
it matters to you because you care about
the people in that there's a physical
change in your brain that is the memory
if you remember what I'm saying now for
more than a few moments that is a
physical change
your brain so all of us in earth
sciences are amazed by that how can we
physically change the brain to be the
biological record of a memory that we
can keep and use in the future and the
Engram Carl Ashley said is represented
throughout the brain is spread
throughout the brain here's why he
thought that so he was working with rats
and they ran a maze right and you saw
how quickly you learned the maze to go
from start to finish to get the food if
you're if you're a rat and here's what
he found and it the results won't amaze
you to start with ok so what he did is
he made this is number of errors during
learning so it's good to be low and this
is how much neocortex they took out
ranging from 10% to 80% and he said he
discovered the more neocortex you took
out the worst learner you were now if it
didn't happen in some broad sense we'd
say well what part is of us is learning
it right you take out more brain you're
less of a good reader right 10% out 10%
bad memory 50% of brain out 50% of bad
memory 9 80 percent of the brain out 80%
bad memory right right ok that makes
sense but what he was really impressed
by is it didn't seem to him to matter
where he took the brain out of the rat
it just didn't matter it's just the
percent that he took out whatever
percent he took out is how bad a learner
you were and we'll come back to that but
that's why I said it must be spread
everywhere because wherever I take out
brain part of the memory is weakened or
disappears and sometimes people call
that mass action for a distributed
memory that spread throughout the brain
in this math ways this we were just
spread all over the place and a single
clinical case and I'll spend a few
moments on him for two reasons it is the
historical case that turned this around
and I have a particular perspective on
this because when I was a graduate
student I did a lot of work with the
single patient whose case turned around
our understanding of the mammalian brain
and memory ok so as I start to talk
about and this is one I can't tell you
what Phineas Gage was really like beyond
what I read or gay or Broca's patients
from the 1900s I can tell you what HM
the man were about to talk about was
like as I spent many many hours with him
two blocks from here when I was a
graduate student in Suzanne Corkins lab
so the structure we'll focus on is
something called the hippocampus it
looks sort of big in the picture and
it's about the size of about two-thirds
of your thumb one on the left and one on
the right in the
in size or the medial part of the
temporal lobes pretty small percentage
of the brain and you can see it uh you
know it's located here here to sort of
drawn-out and here's the story of this
man he died a couple years ago there's
lots of plays and movies and books in
the works okay I can also tell you that
when I was a graduate student here my
fellow graduate students would say tell
us who HM what does his initials really
stand for as if it really mattered
particularly here but I felt privileged
to have the secret knowledge of what his
name was when he died they published it
everybody knows now so my secret is out
but um our RC crews that would he was
born in 1926 at age 16 hit his first
major epileptic seizure that by age 27
he was having many many seizures a day
you can have petit mal seizures where
you tune out from the world you can have
grand mal seizures that lead to physical
convulsions by age 27 the medications
were not helping him in 1953 very much
that were available and he was just
sitting in his house just waiting for
the next seizure basically that was his
life he was a man of normal intelligence
and sort of fairly typical average
background nothing remarkable and in
order to treat the epilepsy William
Scoville the surger surgeon receptive or
took out surgically the tissue
here's his cartoon of what he took out
the hippocampus also the amygdala just
in front of it also tissue that
surrounds it and the reason he took it
out is the single most likely place
where epileptic seizures start is the
hippocampus it's kind of a signal in
many ways that the hippocampus does
something very dangerous its operating
in a some sort of fast speed lane of
neurobiology it's a very sensitive part
of the brain for a lack of oxygen for
diseases we'll talk about Alzheimer's
disease it's a very vulnerable part of
the brain but it does something magical
and essential for memory and so he
couldn't locate where the seizures were
starting very well from him in ways they
typically do so they said okay he has
all these seizures we don't know what to
do let's take out the left and the right
hippocampus in the surrounding tissue
and in terms of seizure control was
pretty successful he had to stay on
medications from that day till he till a
few years ago when he passed away
but he had very very few seizures
compared to before that so was medically
very successful in terms of seizure
control it had a giant side effect from
that day to the pro till a couple years
ago HM never formed a new memory for any
event or for all practical purposes for
any fact that he was exposed to ever
again
despite his normal intelligence and his
uh otherwise intact abilities so they
took an mr of HM it took a long time to
decide they could even take a mr picture
of HM because they were very worried
that if you put him in an mr scanner
this magnetic fields right and often
they put in clips after surgery
regularly they put in clips after the
surgery to keep the vessels from
bleeding and they weren't sure what the
clips were made of for a while and so
they said well we can't put him in
because we could move the clips and kill
him which would be bad so right so they
said it was dangerous and they did a
huge detective process of going to the
factory that made them and talking to
the people who build it before they
decided took like ten years of research
to decide that the clips were not metal
and they could take an mr and even here
here's a top of the brain normal person
here's the hippocampus the small
structure in you pretty small it's
removed in him but you can see he's got
a lot of brain left except for these
removed structures but what happened was
he had such a fantastic impairment and
learning new information that got the
label of a global amnesia global amnesia
it didn't matter that what tests were
hard like remembering stuff or
multiple-choice
he failed practically every standard
test of memory you'd ever give a person
or if it's words or nonsense syllables
faces cliques mazes public events
assassinations of presidents Wars going
to the moon whatever you know whatever
you think of as famous he he didn't know
they happen at all personal events the
death of his own parents if you asked
him how his parents were doing he would
say something like I haven't seen them
for a while he would not know they had
passed away so no matter how publicly
famous something was no matter how
personally important it was that
knowledge he could remember for a few
seconds and we'll talk about that more
but it would drift away completely
within seconds
no matter how often he heard it no
matter how personally important it was
and you could say what does he say his
experience is like so Brenda Milner the
neuropsychologist to the lot of the
critical original research with him
describing his case said that he said
everyday is alone in itself whatever joy
I've had and whatever sorrow I've had I
mean it sounds very poetic and it's true
except that for HM his memory lasts
seconds so he doesn't remember any day
okay since 1950 or something so I think
his experience is more like this right
now I'm wondering have I done or said
anything on this you see at this moment
everything looks clear to me
his mind is clear he's smart but what
happened just before what happened a
minute ago or two minutes ago or five
minutes ago that's what worries me it's
like waking from her dream I just don't
remember all right so he you know when
we worked with him here a few blocks
from here
he would know who I was he would know
why he was here he was an extremely
pleasant and wonderful research
participant a piece of that was he was
very nice and very pleasant a piece of
that was he didn't know time was passing
so if any of you are involved in
experiments as participants sometimes
people you know they enjoy the
experiment for about five minutes but
not for the next 55 okay so we're
getting a lot of measurements to get a
good measurement you know for HM it was
never an hour-long experiment it was
always a min and a half experiment so
you have to be very careful you know not
to abuse that situation as a researcher
so here's his name Henry mOLAISON here's
his uh pictures from his youth and from
this but you see how we had a complete
reversal all of a sudden the removal of
just two small regions the left and the
right hippocampus in the brain stopped
the creation or formation of new
memories altogether in any practical way
so that shows you that memories not
spread throughout the brain and the sort
of undifferentiated mass action way but
that particular parts of the brain play
very particular roles in how memories
are formed and hippocampus plays a huge
role in that can't see it so they had
they had a big project where they
brought him from the nursing home in
Connecticut where he was they drove him
by ambulance to Massachusetts General
Hospital
they overnight did an
like something like an 8-hour MRI scan
on him to have the world's most detail
MRI scan you practically have on anybody
and then they removed his brain and send
it to a laboratory in San Diego where
they took his brain and they sliced it
into many many many incredibly thin
slices that they're going to post on the
web okay at on the web for quite a while
was the slicing of his brain he
consented to this it's you know all he
really is all this research effort and
finally his brain is a you know gift to
research and understanding the brain and
memory
you
so let me tell you a couple of
experiments
salts from him and then you might think
of questions you have about what a man
like this is like okay so we've talked
about last time about that if you give a
list of words to people and you try to
yourself that people remember the first
words best the primacy effect a
long-term memory effect that's not
affected by adding a few seconds of
delay and a recency effect superior
memory for the last few words to the
list that's strongly affected by adding
in just ten seconds of delay from the
last word until you recall and this is
done with other music patients and not
hmm a similar disorder you can see that
their memory is worse overall there's a
dark line but they have some benefit
from the beginning of the list and but
it's small it's not the same as the
controls but they're completely normal
completely normal for the last two or
three words so this is what we mean by
impaired long-term memory and spared
short-term memory but the short-term
memory is just moments but it's not just
an impression you have you know it's a
scientific experiment you can do here's
a note we did this last time we said if
you read digits to people and ask them
to repeat them back aloud that we have a
limited short-term memory of seven plus
or minus two people get to about seven
or eight typically so there's a sort of
mean test that's given to look at
something so here's what they do imagine
that you do this test and you were
correct for two digits correct for three
repeating them back after you heard them
four five six seven you did well and
then you made mistakes at eight okay
which would be very typical for a human
right they find so this is your span
they're four seven that's how much you
can hold and short-term memory it varies
a little bit from person to person and
now they're going to do all the rest of
the experiment at one beyond your span
right one beyond what you can do one
beyond what your short-term memory right
with here's a limit of your short-term
memory let's add one thing and one thing
that we know helps memory is repetition
it's not the best way to learn things
but it is a powerful way to learn things
so now they give the entire experiment
with eight digits at a time for this
person one beyond what you could report
so they give you this and they give you
this but they give you one boost which
is
every third one is the same sequence
over and over again so some you've here
once and once only and one you hear over
and over again is that okay now what
would happens if you think if you hear
eight digits over and over again what
would happen you know this in your own
life your social security number
telephone numbers things what happens
can you learn eight digits if you do it
over yeah it wouldn't be easy but you
can you get you get it right with
repetition so here's what happens in
typical people here's the repetition
here's how well they do for the non
repeated Super span ones they never get
that good because they basically can't
do that occasionally they get lucky but
mostly not but the ones that they repeat
they get better and better so repetition
is another way to break the bounds of
short-term memory and register something
and long-term memory but in HM they did
this for hundreds of trials and he never
got better at the repeated series so you
could do endless repetition with him or
it could be personally important he
wouldn't remember it so let me add one
more piece to the story that's if I talk
to you and say here that you just tell
that back to me that's an auditory
verbal experiments their words and
you're hearing them you can also test
short-term memory and long-term memory
using a visual spatial test of blocks so
you're seeing what the examiner sees
with numbers on the back of each of
these the person taking the test just
sees these blocks as black boxes without
any number you need that because you
have a piece of paper with numbers on it
that tell you what to tap okay so when
you give this test you you might see
five seven eight and you would tap with
your hand five seven eight and the
person would tap that back alright I can
tell you it made me pretty nervous when
I gave this test if a person had a long
one because I'd have to read the numbers
practice it and I'd be desperately
trying to get eight in my head which I
could barely do maybe because I could
tap eight back right so as well as if a
person was good right and then we do the
same thing say if you can do eight we'll
test you at nine and repeat them and
here's two findings and then let's talk
about HM for a moment so one finding is
on now in patience now we're going to
switch one thing a little bit HM had the
left and the right hippocampus removed
in these patients they had either
the left or the right moved either to
the left or the right so here's what
happens for normal controls for the
numbers that are beyond their span not
too good low performance but they
benefit from repetition here's what
happens for the patients with left
hippocampal removals for the
auditory-verbal things for the digits
good at short-term sorry let me get this
right
um right so they're good for immediate
memory for this stuff but they're
terrible at developing a long-term
memory over here it is verbal but the
patients with the right temporal ones
are just fine for spatial things is
exactly the opposite the group that's
really impaired are the patients with a
large right hippocampal of removal and
the people with a left hippocampus who
just fine so we have two separations in
the brain for learning things in the
medial temporal lobes
neither the left nor the right are
involved in short-term memory short-term
memory lasting only seconds the left is
important for verbal long-term memories
and the right is important for long-term
spatial memories which is very
consistent with what we know about left
and right hemispheres for verbal and
spatial knowledge so let me say we're
going to learn more about how we think
about the organization of memory and
we'll come back to this chart so we're
talking here so far about what people
call declarative or explicit memory you
study some material you get tested on it
what did you study and people sometimes
make a difference between two kinds of
things so episodic memory might be if I
ask you okay I needs a volunteer in your
seat it's really easy this one
okay thanks sir I saw some people
getting ready to go but you well okay
I'll start okay what did you have for
breakfast this morning and you don't
have to answer honestly if it's
embarrassing you can just give us a
standard I'm not looking to make yet
cereal how are you young Syrian yogurt -
excellent healthy answers okay so I'm so
now I'm going to ask you if I gotta ask
you first how many feet in a yard
excellent great okay so and I'm gonna
ask you when and where did you learn
that okay and you might go yeah you made
you have a you might go I don't know I
just learned it right or if I ask a
capital of France Paris excellent answer
and when when was the shocking moment
when this was revealed to you when you
say I'll never trust the world again you
know yes who knows right so what you're
learning is episodic memories memory for
specific events like what I did last
night what I had for breakfast specific
time in place semantic memories what we
could call generic memory we know lots
of things about the world but we might
not know when or where we learned it
looks that okay so that's a distinction
psychologists find useful to think about
so how about an HM we've said he can't
remember digits or faces or things like
that
how about generic memory so here's an
experiment that I was involved in where
we said because there were some debates
about this at the time so we gave HM a
multiple-choice test where we saw words
or phrases that entered the language
after the onset of Zim neva okay so we
thought he wouldn't learn - but we
didn't know for sure from just everyday
experience and by the way I should tell
you he watched tons of television okay
what is experience that was like
watching televisions and interesting
questions you should be thinking about
questions you want to ask about HM in a
moment so I'll come back to that but
look at so he has four choices for the
word amniocentesis including the correct
one buddy picks an infectious
inflammatory disease of the intended
apartheid in front of him is the correct
answer
two other answers and he picks the
separation of young cows that have not
yet given birth to calves both people
people cater bon-voyage parties which is
completely the wrong spirit brainwash
the food that surrounds them Bayes
the brain granola portable keyboard wind
instrument software expensive clothing
made of a soft world fabric what's going
on with him are these like crazy weird
answers or how would you what do you
what do we think is going on with him
why is he picking these the other one is
right in front of him what's he doing
yeah he's he's doing what teachers teach
you in school what take apart the word
into its parts right he so he goes soft
where soft clothes that you wear I mean
but what does that mean he's missed in
every sense the advent of computers and
software in the world okay the idea the
concept the words it's as if it didn't
exist because in 1953 all those software
existed it wasn't a very popular concept
right most people didn't know about the
concept of that 1953 the way we looked
at these we looked at these were not
words that work in the dictionary in the
1950s so um so now what would you like
to know about a man like HM yeah
right so you're saying he wouldn't
remember something two days ago but
you're talking with him what's that like
right so let me give you one
experimental thing and then extrude so
one experiment they did is they left him
with something like six numbers okay
well within the span and said remember
these numbers then it could be you know
1 2 3 4 5 cell that wouldn't work so
well yeah 2 4 6 8 9 2 4 6 8 9 - they
leave the room for 15 minutes they come
back in he's a excellent subject is
going to 4 6 8 9 - 4 69 - what would
numbers 2 4 6 and they go that's
excellent
you know it was there any trick you did
to do that or did you just think up what
were the numbers okay
what as soon as a thought is out of his
forefront of his mind it's gone okay so
yeah he would he would not recognize us
if we spent many hours with him a
striking thing which which was amazing
at first and then sometimes some if you
worked with him and he was a delightful
guy um was that he would tell you a
story from his past and he didn't have a
huge array of stories because they were
all from you know a long time ago and he
would tell you like about a gun
collection he had and he would tell you
he had three guns and this property in
that property he'd finish the story and
if you just stayed quiet for a moment he
would forget that he told you the story
but it would be vaguely on his mind
because he just told it to you and he
would say to you hey did I tell you
about my gun collection and he would
tell you almost we're getting the same
story you just wait a moment he forgot
that he told you the story but it's kind
of slightly on his mind because he just
told you it and he goes hey did I tell
you my good he could tell you this as
until you could bear it no longer
okay all right so it was kind of amazing
how short his short-term memory was you
know without this part of the brain it's
just a few seconds his conversations
were ok but I would you know I would
call them pretty shallow I don't know
how to put it you you you you know when
you talk with somebody and you're on the
phone and they're doing something else
and you can tell you know for him was a
little bit like that so he was so good
social convention he would smile he
would chat with you but if it's before
you're talking about dependent and
remembering something from three
sentences ago in any detail gone ok just
seconds unless he's practicing at
practicing or practicing without doing
anything else yeah
that capability to learn procedurally
yes we're going to come to that so the
question is that he ever learned that he
had other kinds of learning that were
amazingly completely normal in him
procedural memory you're absolutely
right and we'll come to that just in
about 20 minutes okay exactly right and
if I don't answer that well make me do
that again okay well yeah yeah yeah
really good question was he able to
remember that he couldn't remember
things yes he knew he had a bad memory
so now the question is in what sense do
you know he had a bad memory like I know
there's I can't draw very well okay uh
amongst many other things I can't do
very well so uh but uh you know if you
talk to him he'd say yeah I don't have a
good memory but you look he's looking at
you and he's going like I don't know
where I am who you are or what I'm doing
everything is vague for many many years
I must have bad memory like you were too
like a science fiction movie you woke up
you didn't know who you were where you
were what you were doing and you can't
remember anything except from the most
distant past news go something is not
good with my memory right but you're
smart so you would know that what I
don't know is if you woke him up at 2
a.m. and you said hm yeah how's your
memory I don't know if he go well I'm a
famous and music of course is terrible
right you know I I don't know if he knew
it as a fact like we might know about
what we're good at not good at what he
just knew it by constantly being aware
that he didn't know anything he ought to
know via memory does that make sense is
that yeah anything else about yeah
Langley
is a very interesting informed consent
you know yeah so technically he was
conserved by the state once his family
had passed away um but you know his
intelligence was fine so he had to be a
little bit careful to do it right but
you could tell him we're going to
experiment we're gonna test your memory
for words is that okay with you and he'd
say yes of course if you had to meet a
12 page document by the time we got to
page 12 but you could talk him through
it
his intelligence was fine you could
worry about the edges if there you know
so I think the investigators you know
felt an extra ethical thing also not to
ask him to do anything that a person
might say no to he was a wonderful
participant but there was an extra
responsibility for the reason your sign
yeah easily happy all the time
excellent question he was a very sort of
mellow yeah yeah well you could think
for a moment where the heaven no memory
would make you happy or sad so he's he
couldn't hold a job he couldn't sustain
a human relation because he would never
know he met you before
uh so those are things we often think is
pretty big in our happiness the kind of
the work we do in some broad sense and
the people we relate to right and those
were all gone for him on the other hand
he didn't exactly realize that he didn't
realize he didn't work he didn't realize
he didn't have relations he might be
expected to have cuz he'd forget that as
bad as fast as he could think about it
so uh so hi he was kind of a very I
would say mild happy person so there's
three possibilities that crossed my head
and scientifically we can never figure
them out one of them is um you know
maybe just he was that way I mean some
people are just mellow and happy right
they don't have without amnesia okay
second possibility is he had removed
also the amygdala we'll talk about that
later in the course that's a structure
that's pretty important for some aspects
of emotion and feeling said that could
have been relevant the third one is but
this is kind of getting to your question
which is intuitively I feel like this
again this is not science but just a
feeling that what makes us mostly sort
of happy or sad for me it's mostly
relatively recent things that were went
well or didn't go well or things you
know things I'm sad about recently and
things on my horizon things
I'm worried about or thinks I'm looking
forward to is that good and you guys
might be different but I don't get that
worked up these days about second grade
all right I mean at the time I'm sure I
was pretty emotional about so-so
so if you think about him you know he
doesn't remember anything kind of recent
that was good or bad he doesn't remember
anything coming up that's interesting or
threatening or risky or unpleasant so he
lives in this constant now we know
people tell you live in the moment
nobody could have lived more in the
moment than he did okay it's impossible
to live more in the moment when the only
the previous moment you can consult is
from 30 40 years ago okay so yeah he was
pretty happy in a pretty Pleasant guy
you know essentially I don't think most
of us want that life although he's
probably happier than many people who
have all their memories right one thing
he's the opposite of just to remind you
is as we talked about it now but just to
make it clear he's the opposite of
television amnesia what happens in soap
opera and murder movies when somebody
gets bonked a comedy shows when they get
bumped on the head
television Tunisia they forget who they
are and where they came from right and
then they marry the worst enemy or
something like this to make the story go
forward right that's television I mean
but after after that they're kind of
fine right they're kind of operating but
it's just forgot where they come okay
that we never see after brain injuries
we never see a person who forgets who
they are but gets around find in the
world hm is the opposite he remembers
stuff from his from before but he can't
learn new things opposite of TV amnesia
right is that okay um any other
questions about HM yeah
yes and let me talk a little bit about
that if I don't answer that
let me know so let me talk about this
this is sort of touches on this loss of
already known information okay if I
don't answer you well make me just put
your hand up again okay so how do we -
it's easy to test learning new things
because you can give somebody something
in the laboratory you see if they learn
it knowing things they should have known
from before is much harder different
people know different things right in
the past so here's how they test it and
here's the thing that people have
discovered which is people are pretty
unknowledgeable about mostly about faces
of people who are famous at the time
they were famous but if you're like 20
you don't know people who are famous
before you were born
mostly there's some fake sections okay
so but so they take faces from different
decades and they show you them and they
ask you do you know who this is so do
you know who this is
this is Lindbergh Frank Sinatra Bob Hope
is that name even ring a bell I know
this is this is totally however old you
are is totally how you do on this test
Lyndon Baines Johnson President I States
after Kennedy Douglas MacArthur the
general this seemed like Richard Nixon
McCarthy light as in McCarthyism go to
my ear
Elvis okay okay now if you pretend you
became a music you became a music
pretend you're old enough to become a
music in 1990 this is if your feeling
would you know this face if you're in
1990 let's make 1980 let's make it
simple 1980
no okay would you know this face no no
no okay but you know them now okay so
that tells you that you can put names to
decade faces two decades roughly and you
know 1980 only Barack Obama's family
knew Barack Obama's face right now we
all did said okay so temporally limited
retrograde amnesia so this is how well
you do higher is better and decades
right so in 1960 here's hm so
here's faces that were famous in the 20s
30s and 40s before he became a music and
he's pretty normal
these are public faces and then he's
terrible for the 50s and 60s after his
Denisha so his memory for faces from the
past is pretty normal his memory for
faces from the onset of the news forward
is terrible
okay does that answer your question
reasonably okay um yeah but here's
another really weird thing that people
have observed in many cases which is
kind of hard to understand but but it's
been observed in many cases so here's a
another patient he was a bus driver in
Washington DC he moved to work in a
drugstore in Boston than a mattress
Factory in Boston then he was
hospitalized at the Boston VA in
November 1965 with a huge hematoma and
the right term people probably big
bleeding and he was pretty aphasic and
stuporous he couldn't answer questions
in a month
he's digit span and short-term memory
returns he states the date as
approximately something like September
1965 he is a severe and terribly in Asia
for example he fails to learn the names
of the nurses he sees every day but when
asked this is what the striking thing he
says targeting me when asked where do
you live he says I live in Washington
with certainty as if he lost all these
memories from before by March he starts
to learn the nurses name he's recovering
his memory capacity he couldn't remember
that he moved to Boston but he doesn't
fight the idea that he lives in Boston
then he remembers he worked at a
drugstore then he remembers that he
worked in a mattress Factory and by the
time he's discharged it's only the last
24 hours before he went to the hospital
he's lost so two things there's a
coupling between the interrogate amnesia
and the retrograde amnesia he can't
learn new things but he lost old things
and as the interrogator amnesia resolves
the retrograde amnesia resolves in some
sense in temporal order it's really odd
it's been observed many times so so
there is some link between what the
hippocampus does and memory for the past
now it's in some ways that's really hard
to study these things in detail in a
patient like HM but in some other
patients give us another perspective
although every one of these examples is
not quite perfect
here's patients who undergo treatment
for depression
with electroconvulsive therapy and
appropriately in movies like One Flew
Over the Cuckoo's Nest
you know wrongly used electroconvulsive
therapy is wrong for some patients with
severe depression who failed to respond
to medications and who have suicidal
ideation literally attempt to take their
lives or talked a lot about it in a
believable way to family and physician
electroconvulsive therapy can be very
helpful it's a hard choice to make in a
complicated one here's what happens
patients typically go and it varies but
they go in for the electroconvulsive
therapy and nowadays has done typically
only the right hemisphere in this study
done some years ago around 1972 it was
bilateral they put electrodes on both
sides of the brain they pass current and
they induce a seizure and a remark and
they do that on something like every
second day for about ten days it's a
very you know aggressive form of
treatment certainly but for some
patients the depression just lifts and
they're no longer talking about taking
their lives so for some people it seems
to work when other things don't during
the course of the treatment these
patients develop an and Terra great
amnesia they become HM like while
they're in the hospital to become HM
like they can't learn new things they
forget the nurses you can test them
formally and so Larry squirter
did the following experiment with these
consultations so we don't know that it's
the hippocampus that's the critical
thing in these patients but it look a
lot like HM and we know that the
hippocampus has a low seizure threshold
that's why it occurs so often as the
locus of epilepsy so what they did is
they took television shows now this is
another world and you can possibly
imagine I grew up in a world where there
were basically three television stations
and you're feeling sad for me already
and so everybody knew what was on those
three television stations or and but
they took shows that weren't very
successful that we're on for one season
only okay so they weren't super popular
but a lot of people saw them and there
were only three television station
networks and stations so when they did
they tested them on these events or
other things like that
before they had ECT so this is their
knowledge before they had a CT of course
they remember recent things 1971 better
than stuff from years ago okay like it
we all do but the striking thing is when
these patients got ECT during the course
of their aneasha
the only lost memory for TV shows from
the last two years they didn't lose this
memory these are the very same patients
the very same patients before they got
ECT and while they're getting ECT they
lose memory only for the last two years
of TV shows and not all the other ones
or same thing you can do with famous
public events so this is what people
call a temporally limited retrograde
amnesia
it goes back for some years of knowledge
you already had and here's the amazing
thing when these patients go home the
memory largely comes back and so does
their knowledge of the TV shows it's as
if it's in their brain they don't have
access to it for the last two years of
information but it's still sitting there
and they regained that access to more
examples on this so here's an example
because with humans is always tough so
they did the same thing with monkeys
with monkeys they could do you know
create a surgical lesion like HM and
train them on material they knew exactly
what they learned here they had the
surgery either two four eight or twelve
or eight sixteen weeks and you can see
the monkeys with the hippocampal damage
we're performing poorly if they learn
the material two or four weeks ago but
not you know eight or sixteen weeks ago
again a temporally limited Retro greater
than usual so we're getting the idea
that the hippocampus is important not
only for forming new memories but and
this is kind of wild it's still
important for you to remember stuff from
a week ago a month ago and a couple
years ago and it takes years for your
memory to become independent or what
people call consolidated so that it no
longer depends upon the hippocampus all
right so the campus both is required to
form a new memory and it seems like it's
necessary to remember that memory you
know from months to years before that
memory becomes independent of the campus
so right now in you it's as if you had a
neuro chemistry team finishing your
memories you know from the end of eighth
grade okay we're done we're moving on in
ninth grade okay because it takes years
for your hippocampus to no longer be
required to get those memories that you
acquired years ago and the same thing
they did these famous faces like the
ones I showed you before so they said to
be somewhat older people here
activation in the 1990s if they were
looking at famous faces and the
experiment was done in the nineteen
nineteen ninety so recent faces if a
campus or not but not for the 80s 70s or
60s or 50s or 40s again is if the
hippocampus were required to retrieve
memories that's in the rest of your
brain for some time period but then
after much time passes it's no longer
required this summarizes those things so
now Tyler if we could do the film so
we're gonna show you a music patient
most in these equations are like this
man very intelligent very verbal not
dramatic but with terribly impaired
memory
you
so last part of the talk is I'd like to
talk to said back this idea of memory
systems of procedural memory the idea
that you're a symphony of the neural
systems that learn different things so
your brain is like the University right
are going to chemistry department
biology department cognitive science or
economics in you are multiple very
specialized learning circuits that are
good for learning different things so
the idea of a memory system a particular
part of brain that has a particular
nning process and a key concept of that
is so probably been talking about with
people with normally calm memory
explicit or direct testing you know what
did you study
what year is that you're asked directly
to do something but another way to show
memory and learning is through changes
in performance with practice so people
will sometimes call the first kind
declarative memory where you directly
have conscious memory about facts and
that business you know that you know
something like that something occurred
and then the other kind we'll talk about
now procedural memory accessible only
through performance and knowing how now
with these kinds of skill learning or
procedural memory we see how people get
better when they practice getting better
is a change in your behavior that's
learned and a change in your brain that
performs the superior performance so
here's the experiments and that was the
original one friend emitted with HM
where you have to trace a star in a
mirror you see your hand in the mirror
but you don't have direct move your hand
if any of you have done something like
this for some odds-and-ends reason
anybody for sometimes do I see a hand no
okay it's surprisingly hard the
horizontals and verticals are pretty
easy the diagonals as you move your hand
you go oh it's no problem I just reverse
everything and you see your hand just
drift the wrong way okay and you go okay
no no no I just have to you know go 45
degrees different but I could do it and
if you're controlling your hand but then
you move again and it still goes the
wrong way and so at first you make lots
of mistakes we understand this because
you have such automaticity between what
you see and how you move all the time -
the mirror verse you have to overcome
that automatic relationship so first you
make a lot of mistakes and move slowly
you practice you get better here's the
remarkable thing with age so here's hm
each of these dots is you know the next
time he does it
consecutively he gets better from do
get over and over again that's not a
shock here's a shock he comes to the
next day he he keeps to learning he had
and he gets better comes in day three he
keeps learning now for him a day is like
infinity okay for memory when he comes
in the room he says what do I do with
this you go what we did it the last two
days don't you know he said no I have no
idea have you done this before no you
can give him multiple choice of
different things he might have done
he'll pick the wrong thing when you come
in on day three and you're this good
you're pretty proud in fact vain okay
you're going like I can do this I'm
awesome you know this let me add it
right okay because you know that you did
it you know how good you are through
practice he has no idea but his learning
is entirely normal not just better than
you think just as good as you so a
memory system in his brain a different
one in the hippocampus has recapped that
memory uses that memory and the amazing
thing is means that that's also true in
you as far as we understand these things
okay when you learn a physical or mental
skill a lot of it is learned in a way
that has nothing to do with your memory
that you learn the skill it's all by
doing and it doesn't depend on the
hippocampus and some years later I sort
of did this again a little bit
here's his performance first second
third day a week later two weeks later
and a year later complete retention for
a man who can forget within moments a
year later a skill he forgets that he
did it ever within moments so another
kind of task that people do same idea
motor school you can lose is called
roadway pursuit there's a disk like this
that revolves around a platter that
turns pretty fast your job is to
maintain contact between this is sort of
sad before video games right this is
about as interesting as 1940s games got
okay it is whizzed around and you're
Janna is fast enough that it's not easy
to do and a first-year hand goes off it
but with practice you get really good at
revolving with the rotating disc and
um-hm and patients like him learn that
very well another motor skill so who's
bad at learning this which part of the
brain is your instrument for learning
skills through practice so our best
evidence comes from patients with a very
difficult disease called Huntington's
disease that's genetic rare disease it's
onset is in 30s or 40s these patients
get severe motor problems and movement
problems
then over time cognitive ones and
psychiatric ones there's no treatment
for it so this is the caudate withering
away and a patients with Huntington's
disease compared to a healthy person's
postmortem or if you look at an MRI
here's your basal ganglia here's the
withered away basal ganglion the
patients with Huntington's disease and
there's a brief Tyler there's a brief
video of a patient with early stage
Huntington's disease
you
so it's not the most of your problem
they have but when they do one of these
motor kinds of tasks
here's normal typical people learning a
motor task getting better on it's good
to be high on this graph here's the
patients with Huntington's disease
showing no learning at all and this is a
test and these efficiently learn
normally so very convincing and you
could say well they have a motor problem
they're not going to get a motor skill
so one thing they do is they make the
platter or the turn very slowly so at
the beginning they're doing just as well
and they still so no learning at all so
there's a lot of other evidence sparked
by this this it just shows that the
basal ganglia is an instrument that's
essential for us to learn physical or
motor skills perceptual skills in a
variety of cognitive skills as well
things where we practice practice
practice to become excellent basal
ganglia is doing a lot of that work for
you the last kind of learning I'll talk
to you about
and the last disease is a sort of odder
form of learning called repetition
priming it's a change in performance
because of something you did recently
and if I give you a concrete example it
will feel better so here's one of many
examples imagine you study a list of
words like stamp landmark speed clock
you study a list of words like these I
can give you an explicit or declarative
memory test what words did you see you'd
recall them or which were did you see
that we need multiple-choice that's
regular memory we know depends on the
hippocampus I can also give you a weird
test like this which says tell me the
first where do you think of that starts
with sta now if you have good memory
you'll go do you want me to give you
stamp ok is that the point you go no no
no they go Gian thing you want to know
some weird things I'm going to think of
an ego no no no just tell me the first
word you think of ok and you can give
many answers that are all perfectly fine
it can give stall stands staccato star
right many s da words either pick and
all them are fine that's all you have to
do but if you saw stamp one particular
completion of this about 10 minutes ago
you're biased or prime to come up with
that word not all the time but much more
than by chance a recent experiences
biases you to be
and here's the remarkable thing when you
do this experiment with hm if you just
had the list of words and you wait about
20 seconds here's you recall now you're
not surprised that we call from a
healthy persons about seven words right
you try that yourself hm sadly is no
score because he always goes like what
list okay so no recall multiple-choice
recognition where there are three
choices here's typical people hmm about
chance the probability above chance that
you give stamp as the completion to sta
if you saw stamp if I showed you star
probably you could start the specific
word you saw ten minutes ago perfectly
the same in HMS normal control subjects
is just as influenced by that word he
thought ten minutes ago as you are to
give you that answer okay so this got
people very excited because they said
now we can experimentally scientifically
study something that Freud talked about
as a very vague idea the cognitive
unconscious he's not conscious that he
saw a list of words ten minutes ago but
it's making him choose to behave in a
certain way now now you have both things
in you as far as we understand it you
can both remember you saw the word list
but if you switch your thinking a little
bit your behavior a little bit the
unconscious system gets into the
driver's seat right because the people
with good memory we're giving stamped
often but no more or less than hm
so unconscious so what part of the brain
does this kind of memory and our insight
to that comes from Alzheimer's disease
so these is HMS kind of amnesia
extremely rare Huntington's quite rare
Alzheimer's is tragically calm in fact
what they went to East Boston the area
near Logan and knocked on doors at
people's homes okay not people in
nursing homes at home and they estimated
and there's debates about this I could
back and forth but about half the people
over 85 who answered the door qualified
for diagnosis of Alzheimer's disease
about half okay over 85 there's debates
about this Justin Bates about whether
all of us would get it if we live long
enough you know but as American society
gets older as us baby boomers all move
into our you know 60s 70s and 80s
there's going to be a heck of a lot of
people around with Alzheimer's disease
and severe if you use some of you
probably have experienced this with
grandparents that nothing else it's a
very devastating disorder for the
patient for the spouse or family it's a
very challenging disorder so what is
Alzheimer's disease well behaviorally
it's an insidious and progressive
dementia dementia means unlike hm it's
many losses of abilities unlike hm-hm
had a surgery one day boom that was it
Alzheimer starts very slowly gets worse
and worse over time the biggest problem
early on is memory the most common
problem but over time language thinking
concentration spatial thinking sometimes
mood and personality all of these get
altered over time in the brain when you
look at the changes you see that the
changes occur especially in the
hippocampal region so that that's why
the memory problem is like HM and also
in some other parts of the cortex but
not so much for example in basal ganglia
that we just spoke about as important
for procedural memory here's a control
brain and an equal age Alzheimer's brain
the reason why these gyri does this all
site widen is because of widespread
neuronal shrinkage or death and what's
happening inside the brain with the most
important post mortem there's sort of
neurofibrillary tangles and plaques that
are associated with the disease these
are tangles are something about the
cells that have died the plaques are
thought to be maybe part of the process
that leads to the disorder but there's
debate about that to this day and if you
look on post mortem where the tangles
are those tangles up here you can see
their most dense in the hippocampus or
near the hippocampus like hm and so
that's why we think so many patients
with Alzheimer's have an HM like memory
problem and then more problems after
that so here's a healthy person top of
the brain here's the left and right at
the campus
eighty one-year-old and here an 80 year
old Alzheimer's patient the hippocampus
is withered away both sides of the brain
bilaterally
so one more brain perspective on this
this is a SPECT scan that just shows you
where there's blood flow and metabolism
top of the brain bottom of the brain
here's the insides of the temporal lobes
and healthy elderly adults look how much
worse but this is HM he looks pretty
good right you have to look really hard
to see that the hippocampus is missing
because I said a small structure and not
here's an early stage Alzheimer's
patient lots of the tissue is there a
lot of you know it's not functioning
because there's so much damage here's
the medial temporal lobe but also
cortical areas that are compromised okay
again not the biggest problem but in
terms of thinking about different parts
of the brain and what parts of memory
they do so here's a hm so these on these
occasions including HM Alzheimer's
patients and Greene and controls so
recall the list where words were on the
list explicit memory bad in the two
patient crews recognition pretty poor
word stem completion the kind of thing
that we said is completely normal in HM
that's impaired in Alzheimer's disease
so we think that kind of priming depends
on the neocortex the part of the brain
that's also injured in Alzheimer's
because we know it doesn't depend on the
hippocampus because the patient's wood
hippocampus only damaged you're fine so
we end up with a picture like this and
of something on memory system for
explicit or declarative memory from
patients with amnesia we know it depends
on the medial temporal lobe left verbal
right spatial for skill learning
anything you practice many times to get
better at we know from Huntington's
disease that depends on the basal
ganglia four kinds of priming recent
experience altering something about
brain organization Alzheimer's disease
we know from that that it's likely
mediated by the neocortex these are from
patient studies but imaging studies are
very well aligned with these things so
we think it's true not only of patients
you in terms of the instruments of your
brain so now we have not only episodic
memory and semantic memory we talked
about procedural memory but talk about
priming I didn't talk about conditioning
today but we've talked about that before
so I have two more slides to Anam
conceptually so in what sense was Karl
Lashley right or wrong when he said
memories all over the brain here's how
we think about it now we think he was
right that all of your brain is learning
practically all of your brain is plastic
it changes with experience but different
parts of your brain are learning
different things the basal ganglia is
learning how to be skilled at something
the neocortex how to gain knowledge and
shift your representation of knowledge
like in priming the medial temporal lobe
and the left of learning verbal facts
the right is nonverbal factor spatial
effects so all of your brain is learning
that is learning different things and in
that sense we end up with this metaphor
that you know just like there's a string
section right in a percussion section or
something like that in you there's all
these different instruments that are
highly tuned to the way they're
organized to learn all the different
things you learn they're all pretty
useful instruments to have and without
these patients and then the imaging
studies we wouldn't have known that
you'd be like the Martian one
instruments thousand instruments what we
know there's multiple ones and we know
pretty much which structures are
essential for them Thanks
you